[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
[Applaus]
in extremen situationen kann der airbus
a310 mit weg ein geschenk des himmels
sein ein fliegendes krankenhaus 44
patienten kann es im flug versorgen
sechs von ihnen auf einer
intensivstation
normalerweise ein stolzer beweis für
leistungsfähigkeit
jetzt aber ein alarmzeichen dass
deutschlands gesundheitssystem die
letzten reserven mobilisiert
mobilisieren muss intensiv patienten
werden im land um verteilt auf letzte
reserven der intensivabteilung und die
zahlen rasen immer schneller nach oben
mehr als
75.000 neu gemeldete infektionen allein
heute die warnungen aus berlin klingen
allmählich verzweifelt andreas huppert
berichtet
es ist längst zu einem politischen
ritual geworden mahnungen und warnungen
zahlen und daten ein ritual der appelle
die bundespressekonferenz zu corona lage
in deutschland immer mit dabei dennoch
bundesgesundheitsminister und der lkw
chef seit fast zwei jahren geht das
jetzt so
vorletzte woche haben wir gesagt es ist
fünf nach zwölf
letzte woche haben wir gesagt es ist
zehn nach zwölf
es ist mittlerweile halb eins aber der
weckruf ist noch immer nicht überall
angekommen soll niemand behaupten von
der dramatischen lage nichts gewusst zu
haben deutschland im jahr zwei der
pandemie die infektionszahlen so hoch
wie nie
intensivstationen laufen voll manche
über patienten müssen verlegt werden die
bundeswehr leistet medizinische
evakuierungs hilfe fliegt schwerstkranke
von bayern in andere bundesländer aus
70 prozent aller
intensivbereich in deutschland meldet
eine vollständige oder teilweise
eingeschränkte betriebssituation das ist
ein höchststand in der pandemie die
erwarte jetzt von den entscheidern dass
sie alle maßnahmen einleiten um
gemeinsam die fallzahlen
herunterzubringen doch die politischen
entscheider zögern koordiniertes handeln
fehlanzeige da sind die bundesländer die
jetzt nach dem auslaufen der
epidemischen notlage selbst die harten
maßnahmen wie zum beispiel einen
shutdown durchführen müssten sie rufen
nach einheitlichen regeln verantwortet
von einer bundesregierung wenn sie die
situation im gesundheitswesen weiter
zuspitzt werden wir härtere maßnahmen
brauchen diese härteren maßnahmen
brauchen die unterstützung der
bundesregierung und brauchen eine
bessere rechtsgrundlage für jetzt haben
oft der landesebene in bayern wo
teilweise rekord inzidenz wüten fordert
der doch so selbstbewusst der
ministerpräsident die künftige
bundesregierung auf in sachen corona
schnell zu handeln verstehen ist eine
neue regierung bildet sich und man
möchte ich gerne etwas anders machen
dies ist jetzt kein beruf aber es ist
der dringende appell etwas zu tun die
künftige ampel koalition ist momentan
mit sich selbst beschäftigt es geht um
posten und partei internen zwist für
corinna realpolitik fehlt die zeit und
so spart der noch gesundheitsminister
auch nicht mit kritik zu viele auch in
politischer verantwortung oder ein
künftiger verantwortung scheint zu
denken wird schon irgendwie gut gehen
was nicht als schuldzuweisung zu
verstehen sein soll wird aber genau so
verstanden die ampel koalitionäre
schießen zurück ich glaube es wäre gut
wenn der bundesgesundheitsminister sich
darauf konzentriert das hinreichend
impfstoff da ist dass er in kontakt mit
den landesministern dafür sorgt dass die
regeln die möglich sind auch umgesetzt
werden
deutschland im herbst 21 corona
dominiert längst wieder politisches
handeln dieses handeln ist geprägt von
schuldzuweisungen und mangelnder
koordination und so wird es nächste
woche wieder eine coroner lage
pressekonferenz geben wieder mit zahlen
daten und appellen ein trauriges ritual
eben
die lage ist kritisch und dabei hat das
corona virus sarahs kopf zwei sein
potenzial noch längst nicht ausgespielt
die frauen und männer in den
geologischen instituten und bei den
dienstleistern die den bauplan und damit
die gefährlichkeit der viren aus deren
gehen codes herauslesen können warten
sie schon lange auf die nächste böse
überraschung der natur das letzte was
uns jetzt noch fehlt sagte jens spahn
heute morgen wäre eine eingeschleppte
neue variante die noch mehr probleme
macht und ausgerechnet jetzt taucht sie
auf in südafrika schnell erkannt
südafrika ist wissenschaftlich ganz
vorne dabei in der entschlüsselung von
viren varianten sandra theis berichtet
von dort
das christ forschungszentrum in
durban/südafrika hier analysieren
wissenschaftler die verschiedenen co
wird varianten die sich im land
ausbreiten dem team um professor tulio
der oliviera bereitet die neu entdeckte
variante sorgen
sie ist ein grund zur beunruhigung in
südafrika was wir versucht haben
zusammen mit einem netzwerk von kollegen
in südafrika und der regierung ist diese
variante zu einem zeitpunkt zu
identifizieren wo die zahlen gerade erst
anfangen zu steigen und zu wissen bundes
sie es zu tun haben
die neue b 115 29 variante wurde von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
zur omikron variante umbenannt und als
besorgnis erregend eingestuft wie
gefährlich sie ist ist unklar die
forscher stehen noch am anfang aus den
mutationen die diese variante trägt und
der ausbreitung ziehen sie erste
schlüsse weisen aber ausdrücklich darauf
hin dass es sich bislang um vermutungen
handele
es sieht so aus als hätte diese variante
2 der charakteristika die uns am meisten
sorgen machen eine hohe übertragbarkeit
und sie weicht in gewissem maße der
immunabwehr aus
in den vergangenen wochen waren die
infektionszahlen extrem niedrig um die
200 neuinfektionen am tank jetzt stiegen
sie im vergleich dazu sprunghaft an auf
1.200 am mittwoch und mehr als doppelt
so viele gestern vermutlich durch die
neue variante
die gute nachricht auch die omikron
variante lässt sich mit einem pcr test
nachweisen
trotzdem haben einige länder
reisebeschränkungen verhängt darunter
auch deutschland ab morgen dürften
fluggesellschaften nur noch deutscher
nach deutschland befördern so der
geschäftsführende gesundheitsminister
sparen grund sei die schwierige lage in
deutschland an unser ziel muss sein den
eintrag dieser variante so weit es geht
zu vermeiden
das ist das letzte was wir jetzt in
unserer momentanen lage noch brauchen
können das in die welle hinein noch eine
zusätzliche variante kommt andere länder
haben den flugverkehr mit südafrika
komplett eingestellt am internationalen
flughafen in johannesburg versuchten
heute viele das land noch schnell zu
verlassen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt
ausdrücklich vor reisebeschränkungen
solange noch gar nicht klar sei wie
gefährlich die variante wirklich ist
es ist wichtig zu sagen dass jede
reisebeschränkungen abgewogen werden
muss und das länderspiel tun können
durch kontrolle und sequenzierung
wie effektiv die impfstoffe gegen die
omikron variante sind wird jetzt
erforscht das südafrikanische institut
für übertragbare krankheiten geht
derzeit davon aus dass eine impfung mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit zumindest vor
einem schweren verlauf schützt
sicher ist das nicht europa und die
bundesregierung haben schon reagiert
nicht nur der staat südafrika
der ganze süden des kontinents gilt ab
morgen mitternacht als virusvarianten
gebiet das heißt von dort nach
deutschland einreisen dürfen nur
staatsbürger und solche mit festen
wohnsitz hier und das gelten zwei wochen
quarantäne
die virologin ulrike protzer lehrt und
forscht an der tu in münchen einen
schönen guten abend frau professor
bettina wendt eine variante die
besorgnis erregt das ist die offizielle
sprachregelung der whu wie besorgt sind
sie
schon ein bisschen denn diese variante
hat potenzial das sie zum einen
ansteckender ist als das was wir bisher
kennen und zum anderen sich dadurch halt
auch schneller ausbreitet so momentan
zumindest die datenlage nun gibt es ja
zwei arten von schlimmen varianten die
einen sind ansteckender und die anderen
überwinden unter umständen den
impfschutz den wir in deutschland zu 75
prozent inzwischen mühsam aufgebaut
haben ist auch das drin
das wissen wir noch nicht was man
gesehen hat ist dass es ein anstieg von
infektionen gab obwohl es in südafrika
ja gerade wirklich mitten im sommer ist
und dass dort sehr niedrig bleiben
sollte und das ursächlich für diesen
anstieg der infektionen in der gegend um
johannesburg herum diese neue variante
ist und sie hat relativ schnell lokal
dort auch die momentan zirkulierende
delta variante verdrängt daraus schließt
man dass sie einfach ansteckender ist ob
sie sich besser durchsetzen kann wenn
jemand genesen ist oder geimpft ist als
ob es der immunantwort entgehen kann das
ist komplett unklar wie muss man sich
jetzt in den tagen bis das klarer wird
verhalten kann man sagen es sind in
europa ja noch nicht in nennenswerter
zahl dieser liga angekommen warten wir
mal ruhig 34 tage ab oder etwa eine
woche und dann weiß man genauer oder
muss man jetzt schon auf die
vollbremsung drehten weil es dann unter
umständen zu spät sein könnte
wenn man viel reiseverkehr hat zwischen
südafrika und dem jeweiligen land dann
sollte man sicherlich diesen
reiseverkehr einschränken wir haben
südafrika als varianten gebiet
deklariert dh der jemand der zurück
kommt aus südafrika muss zwangsläufig
mindestens 14 tage in quarantäne gehen
wird dann auch getestet wird überprüft
aber wir haben bis jetzt noch nicht
komplett den flugverkehr eingestellt wie
das zum beispiel die briten schon
gemacht haben aber das könnte man
vermutlich auch tun denn so wahnsinnig
viele menschen reisen ja im moment nicht
von südafrika jetzt nach deutschland und
damit wäre man vielleicht noch auf der
sicheren seite nun zur lage in
deutschland wir haben heute etwa
72.000
neuinfektionen nach etwas über 50.000
vor einer woche ist der anstieg auf
100000 am tag überhaupt noch zu bremsen
das ist schwer zu sagen das hängt im
moment tatsächlich von jedem einzelnen
ab die impfungen sind notwendig und die
bären das geschehen insgesamt
längerfristig einbremsen aber ganz
kurzfristig in den nächsten zwei drei
vier wochen ist es unser verhalten wie
viele kontakte haben wir wie stark
tragen wir das virus weiter zu anderen
und können damit auch die ausbreitung
sozusagen befördern also das hängt jetzt
wirklich vom einzelnen ab und wie sehr
wir unsere kontakte reduzieren warum ist
es eigentlich notwendig auch menschen
die geimpft sind unter umständen auch
menschen die gmk und getestet sind jetzt
an ihrem freien leben zu hindern es war
doch immer gesagt worden in der
geimpften getestet seid dann seid ihr
für niemanden gefährlich
das problem was wir gerade haben ist das
die antwort
nachlässt die lässt über die zeit nach
so ab 5 hunderten etwa und bei uns sind
die meisten jetzt einfach schon fünf
oder mehr monate her geimpft das heißt
deren schutz lässt nach und die brauchen
jetzt dringend eine dritte impfung damit
sind wir noch nicht so weit wie wir uns
vielleicht wünschen würden und bisher
dort sind also mindestens 50 prozent der
menschen auch dritt geimpft haben so
lange müssen wir leider auch für die
geimpften
restriktionen in kauf nehmen ist es denn
überhaupt noch denkbar oder andersrum
ist es illusorisch zu glauben dass man
in deutschland in der gegenwärtigen lage
noch um großflächige lockt downs
herumkommt
ich glaube dass man lockt es braucht in
den hotspots da wo also wirklich ein
sehr hohes infektionsgeschehen ist da wo
die krankenhausaufnahmen schon sehr hoch
sind und die krankenhäuser
drohen damit einfach nicht mehr fertig
zu werden aber das ist ja nicht in ganz
deutschland gleichermaßen der fall wir
haben regionen in denen sehr gut geimpft
wurde bremen als beispiel und wir haben
regionen in dem deutlich weniger geimpft
wurde sachsen thüringen auch bayern und
da muss man glaube ich schon regionale
unterschiede machen und auf die
krankenhaus belastung und auf die
ansteckungszahlen schauen und dann
entscheiden und die zeit der
entscheidungen ist jetzt die zeit der
entscheidung ist definitiv jetzt danke
für das gespräch und einen schönen abend
und
wir haben dieses gespräch vorab geführt
ich habe mich da in der frage bei den
neuinfektionen vertan das waren heute
nicht
72.000 sondern
76.000 neue fälle und nun korrekt und
zuverlässig wir über nachrichten von
gundula gause die bundesländer fordern
mehr zeit um die bundesmittel für den
ausbau der ganztagsbetreuung in
grundschulen abzurufen
750 millionen euro stehen dafür bis
jahresende zur verfügung diese frist
solle bis ende 2022 verlängert werden
beantragt der bundesrat wegen der
pandemie habe sich der ausbau verzögert
außerdem hat der bundesrat vier monate
nach der flutkatastrophe im westen
deutschlands einer verordnung zum
sogenannten cell broadcast zugestimmt
mit dieser technologie sollen
katastrophenwarnungen künftig schneller
an alle handys verschickt werden können
die afg verschiebt wegen der korona lage
ihren mitte dezember in wiesbaden
geplanten bundesparteitag auf das
kommende jahr aus verantwortung
gegenüber den delegierten sei ein
präsenz parteitag nicht durchführbar so
der einstimmige beschluss des
bundesvorstandes bereits zweimal hat die
afg in corona zeiten präsenz parteitage
abgehalten jetzt steht auch eine neuwahl
der parteispitze an von der sich jörg
neunten zurückzieht
frankreich und italien stärken ihre
zusammenarbeit und wollen intensiver
kooperieren bei diplomatie und
verteidigung bei der gestaltung des
digitalen und ökologischen wandels sowie
in wissenschaft und industrie
frankreichs präsident makro und italiens
regierungschef draghi unterzeichneten im
quirinalspalast in rom einen
umfangreichen vertrag und würdigten den
historischen moment ziel sei auch ein
souveränes europa
nach mehreren tagen wartezeit auf sie
darauf dass deutsche rettungsschiff cj4
im hafen von augusta auf sizilien
anlegen an bord seien rund 460 im
mittelmeer gerettete menschen so die
private hilfsorganisation
zuvor hatte die crew den notstand an
bord ausgerufen weil das schiff in einen
sturm geraten waren
als am mittwoch an frankreichs küste 27
menschen starben 17 männer sieben frauen
drei kinder ertrunken sind als sie in
einem völlig seeuntüchtigen schlauchboot
versuchten von calais aus über den kanal
nach england zu kommen da haben die
regierungen in london und paris nicht
gezögert sondern sofort gehandelt
routiniert nämlich gleich wieder einen
streit angefangen werden schuld sei
mittlerweile hat der ton schriller
frequenzen erreicht unsere london
korrespondentin erklärt den streit und
die zusammenhänge die größer sind als
europa
auch gestern sind wieder migranten in
kent angekommen menschen die sich im
schlauchboot auf die verkehrsreichste
schiffsroute der welt getraut haben um
nach großbritannien zu gelangen sowie
die 27 dies am mittwoch nicht geschafft
haben sondern im eiskalten wasser
gestorben sind reflexhaft beschuldigt
die britische innenministerin die
franzosen ihren job nicht richtig zu
machen warnte genth ich möchte mein
angebot an frankreich noch einmal sehr
klar machen und das lautet britisch
französische kooperation in form
gemeinsamer patrouillen die solche
gefährlichen überfahrten verhindern
die franzosen lehnen das ab so wie sie
auch ablehnen was boris johnson gestern
in einem öffentlichen brief vorschlug in
großbritannien ankommende asylbewerber
sollten künftig einfach nach frankreich
zurück geschickt werden im mangel marco
reagierte empört inhalt und form
verrieten einen mangel an
ernsthaftigkeit
und komiker regierungschefs
kommunizieren zu solchen fragen nicht
per twitter oder offenen brief wir sind
doch keine whistleblower also wirklich
hallo von einem treffen der eu
migrationsminister am sonntag wurde die
britische kollegin ausgeladen die
stimmung zwischen franzosen und briten
es seitdem rexit ohnehin sehr angespannt
heute etwa blockierten fischer britische
fähre von calais sie fordern besseren
zugang zum britischen fischgründen
während sie sich gegenseitig
beschuldigen verantwortlich zu sein
versuchen beide seiten doch immer nur
die leute davon abzuschrecken diese
überfahrt anzutreten anstatt einen
legalen weg zu etablieren wie man asyl
in großbritannien beantragen kann ohne
sein leben zu riskieren
die migranten kommen momentan häufig aus
den kurdengebieten im irak und in syrien
sie reisen nach belarus wo sie in den
vergangenen wochen über die grenze nach
polen gelassen wurden viele bleiben in
der eu etwa 2500 warten momentane der
gegend von calais darauf überzusetzen
großbritannien lockt sie wegen der
sprache viele haben familie dort oder
hoffen im völlig deregulierten
britischen arbeitsmarkt leicht unter
schlüpfen zu können legal gibt es fast
keinen weg in großbritannien asyl zu
beantragen
denn die grenzkontrollen werden auf
französischem boden durchgeführt noch
ich fordere mehr engagement von
britischer seite ich möchte hier daran
erinnern dass wir in gewisser weise die
grenze für die bringen sichern und diese
frauen und männer wollen ihr asyl nicht
in frankreich
die asylsuchenden künftig einfach nach
großbritannien durch zu lassen damit
drohen bislang nur die französischen
oppositionsparteien noch hat london die
gelegenheit zu erkennen dass man dragset
hin oder her die meisten krisen besser
gemeinsam löst
und noch haben nicht alle verstanden wie
nah an europa das scheinbar ferne
unglück ist coronaviren können einem das
erklären auch über das große geld
weltweit haben die finanzmärkte reagiert
und sind wegen der neuen mutationen auf
talfahrt gegangen zum ende dieser woche
also deutliche verluste
nach einer wochenlangen rekordjagd zu
immer neuen höchstständen stefanie
bareth das ist ja immer auch ein
immenser werteverlust wer hat denn die
größten verluste zu verzeichnen
ja im prinzip alles was reißt und fliegt
gerade hatte er die reisebranche etwas
hoffnung geschöpft nun stehen wieder
lockdown und konjunkturängste im raum
tief im minus lufthansa fraport und auch
die deutsche bank aktien der
finanzinstitute standen unter druck weil
mit den neuen virus sorgen das thema
höhere zinsen natürlich wieder in weite
ferne rückt denn sollte die wirtschaft
erneut stark leiden und von den
zentralbanken längere zeit gestützt
werden müssen sind das keine guten
nachrichten nicht nur für banken und
gerät die wirtschaft wieder ins stocken
braucht man auch weniger öl das barrel
verbilligte sich im tagesverlauf prompt
um 11 prozent zu den gewinnern zählten
heute die pandemie profiteure darunter
zalando helau fresh sowie der
laborausrüster satorius aktien des
impfstoffherstellers bei und tag konnten
an der nasdaq sogar um 14 prozent
zulegen weltweit erlebten anleger einen
rabenschwarzen freitag der dax verbuchte
den größten tagesverlust seit beginn der
pandemie und stürzte um mehrere 100
punkte oder gut 4 prozent ab lange zeit
schien es so als hätten die aktienmärkte
die korona pandemie bereits abgehakt mit
der neuen variante könnte sich das bild
nun ändern vielen dank stefanie nach
frankfurt
die grüne woche
2022 fällt aus angesichts der wucht der
vierten corona welle sagte die messe
berlin alle großveranstaltungen bis ende
februar ab und damit auch die
international bedeutende agrar und
ernährungsmesse ende januar zum fußball
in der bundesliga hat der vfb stuttgart
am abend mainz 05 zu gast gerade eben
gegen die partie zu ende mit einem 2 1
sieg der stuttgarter
in braunschweig konnte die
fußball-nationalmannschaft der frauen
ihren fünften sieg im fünften wm
qualifikationsspiel feiern die
mannschaft von bundestrainerin von
tecklenburg gewann 8 zu 0 gegen die
türkei start des matches lea schüler sie
erzwang bereits in der ersten minute ein
eigentor der gegnerinnen mit drei
weiteren toren baute die torjägerin von
bayern münchen die führung ihrer
mannschaft aus am dienstag geht es in
das letzte quali spiel gegen portugal
er habe gestern wird in den annalen des
fc bayern münchen noch lange lebendig
bleiben es war der schlimmste in der
lebenden vereinsgeschichte und nicht auf
dem platz uli hoeneß hat die
hauptversammlung
2021 so beschrieben uli hoeneß ein mann
der sich in höhen und tiefen aus kennt
wie kein anderer und es ging noch nicht
mal um tore es ging um geld um den
anstand und wie beides zusammen hält im
big business zwischen münchen und katar
berufe gegen den bayern präsidenten
nicht wegen 100 millionen euro
umsatzeinbußen in corona zeiten sondern
wegen des millionenschweren sponsor
vertrags mit dem umstrittenen wm
ausrichter katar die kritik soll immer
sachlich und darf nüchterner basis
erfolgen
einem ort war die niederträchtig oder
feige passt beispielsweise überhaupt
nicht zum ton bei unserm fc bayern
münchen und
vereinsmitglied michael ott scheitert
wie schon zuvor beim landgericht münchen
auch beim versuch per spontan antrag den
millionenschweren werbevertrag per
satzungsbeschluss zu beenden sie können
gerne buchen ich werde hier nicht
zulassen dass wir rechtswidrige über
rechtswidrige anträge abstimmen ob ihnen
das probieren
[Applaus]
sie betonen immer wieder wie wichtig der
dialog ist aber sie schaffen es nicht
einmal mit den eigenen mitgliedern und
mit menschenrechtsorganisationen einen
konstruktiven dialog zu kommen dafür
streiten jetzt schon anwaltskanzleien ob
wir hier über katar abstimmen oder reden
dürfen es gibt ganz ganz klar
compliance-anforderungen das machen wir
mit jedem partner und wir schauen uns
das ganz genau an abgestimmt haben knapp
750 anwesende auch gegen die satzung
neufassung des präsidiums aber für die
einhaltung von un menschenrechts
richtlinien bei den bayern geht es
weiter hoch her damit wir schließlich
die
jahreshauptversammlung
[Applaus]
die alarmierenden entwicklung der korona
krise haben auch das feld der
öffentlichen meinung umgepflügt die
zahlen dazu jetzt von matthias fornoff
von dir sagen bis morgen
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
mehr als 100.000 menschen sind in
deutschland mit corona gestorben und die
aussichten bleiben düster die ersten
patienten müssen aus überlasteten
intensivstationen verlegt werden das
krankenhaus system steht vielerorts vor
dem kollaps dazu die sorge vor einer
neuen virus variante aus südafrika
angesichts immer neuer rekordstände bei
den infektionen überzeugt die meisten
deutschen das krisen-management der
politik nicht nur
31 prozent der deutschen denken dass bei
uns zum schutz vor corona genug getan
wird eine deutliche mehrheit von 63
prozent sieht das nicht so
so viele wie noch nie sorgen sich um die
eigene gesundheit für 80 prozent ist
corona jetzt das wichtigste problem in
deutschland
parallel dazu wächst der anteil derer
weiter die sich härtere corona maßnahmen
wünschen auf jetzt 52 prozent doch was
ist der beste weg heraus aus der
pandemie impfen gilt als schlüssel um
das ruder herumzureißen
doch bislang sind hierzulande nur rund
68 prozent vollständig geimpft die
debatte um eine generelle impfpflicht
ist in vollem gange
gut zwei drittel sind jetzt für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht 29 prozent
dagegen im juli als co und weg schien
lehnten fast ebenso viele eine
impfpflicht für alle ab die stimmung hat
sich also komplett gedreht die meisten
wünschen sich mehr härte und
entschlossenheit im kampf gegen korona
gut drei viertel der befragten sind
dafür dass es für ungeimpfte besonders
starke einschränkungen geben sollte 22
prozent finden das nicht richtig
mehrheitlich dagegen sind nur die
anhänger der afd besonders hoch ist die
zustimmung bei den anhängern von spd
union und grünen
letzte woche haben bundestag und
bundesrat das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz beschlossen
ein bundesweiter lockdown ist nicht mehr
vorgesehen und das findet die mehrheit
der befragten auch gut noch mehr
zustimmung gibt es für die 3g regel am
arbeitsplatz 83 prozent
die ampel parteien haben in dieser woche
ihren koalitionsvertrag vorgestellt sie
wollen so die ansage mehr fortschritt
wagen das ist jetzt zu einer koalition
aus spd grünen und fdp kommt finden 55
prozent der deutschen gut im oktober war
die zustimmung mit 62 noch etwas
deutlicher
noch gar nicht im amt muss die neue
regierung bereits die erste harte
prüfung bestehen der mühsam
ausgehandelte
koalitionsvertrag tritt in den
hintergrund der kampf gegen die pandemie
überlagert alles
ob es gelingt die vierte welle zu
brechen wird deshalb auch darüber
entscheiden ob der start der
ampelkoalition als erfolgreich angesehen
wird derweil gibt es in der projektion
wenig bewegung wenn am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre dann käme die spd
unverändert auf 28 prozent cdu/csu lägen
bei 19 prozent minus 1 die grünen 17
prozent plus 1 die fdp läge bei 13
prozent die afg 11 die linke 5 prozent
alle unverändert
die unzufriedenheit mit dem corona
krisen management zeigt sich auch in
unserer liste der wichtigsten politiker
auf der skala von plus 5 bis minus 5
bewertet nach sympathie und leistung ist
jens spahn schlusslicht minus 0,9 mit
den größten verlusten wieder dabei sahra
wagenknecht minus 0,3 davor annalena
baerbock 0,0 verlust in friedrich merz
auf platz sieben 0,0 verbessert
markus söder 0,4 christian lindner 0,8
beide geschlechter auf platz vier neu
dabei lars klingbeil 1,2
platz drei für robert habeck 1,3 auf dem
zweiten platz olaf scholz 1,9 beide mit
verlusten und ganz vorne weiter angela
merkel 2,3 auch sie schlechter
die ampel koalition steht die cdu muss
in die opposition
ein neustart soll her die partei sucht
einen neuen vorsitzenden wer kann die
cdu am erfolgreichsten in die zukunft
führen
friedrich merz sagen 35 prozent der
befragten 26 prozent trauen dass norbert
röttgen zu noch kanzleramtsminister
helge braun mit 14 prozent abgeschlagen
bei den unionsanhängern liegt märz noch
deutlicher vorn
ende januar wird der neue vorsitzende
gewählt
rein digital wie seit heute fest steht
der parteitag feld corona zum opfer wie
so vieles derzeit überall fallen gerade
die lockerungen veranstaltungen werden
abgesagt weihnachtsmärkte geschlossen
das die weihnachtsmärkte in diesem
winter generell abgesagt werden sollten
finden übrigens 49 prozent genauso viele
aber wollen das nicht
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de
wie die repräsentativen umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
10 dezember nach dem wetter geht es hier
gleich weiter mit der heute-show ihnen
noch einen entspannten abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das neue schneetief heißt
andreas und es zieht in den nächsten 24
stunden von der nordsee weiter in
richtung elsass über westeuropa bringt
es auch viel wind mit das sehen sie an
der engen drehung der iso barren der
linien gleichen luftdrucks für uns aber
interessanter ist der schnee das geht ja
schon heute nacht los in der westhälfte
und auch am alpenrand und morgen über
tag ziehen diese schneewolken weiter
ostwärts aber auch in norddeutschland
reicht ist hier und da für eine kleine
weiße überraschung heute nacht sollten
sie sich also auf gefährlich glatte
straßen einstellen es fällt regen
schneeregen und schnee schnee in den
westlichen mittelgebirgen oberhalb von
etwa drei bis vierhundert meter im osten
ist es dagegen trocken glatt kann es
allerdings auch dort sein denn die
temperaturen in dieser nacht sinken auf
werte zwischen plus 3 und minus vier
grad und kühl kalt bleibt es auch morgen
über tag mit höchsttemperaturen von nur
so ein bis fünf grad und es gibt weitere
regen schneeregen und schneeschauern am
längsten schneidest wohl hier am
alpenrand im westen haben sie eine
gewisse chance auch mal die sonne zu
sehen am freundlichsten wird es aber
morgen hier zwischen der uckermark und
dem thüringer wald am ersten advent am
sonntag wird es noch eine spur kühler
mit höchsttemperaturen von minus ein bis
plus vier grad es gibt weitere schnee
und schneeregen fälle und deswegen
könnte es dann sonntagabend in den
bergen für fünf bis 40 cm schneereichen
auch im flachland gibt es hier und da
einen kleinen weißen fleck und ähnlich
winterlich startet dann auch die neue
woche danach wird es milder und
stürmischer wind